swift whip reject nation thank you guys
so much for clicking on this video and i
want to say a special thank you to
everyone who's been sending me stuff on
twitter and instagram keeping me updated
you guys rock guys if you can go ahead
and leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated what we got here today is
andrew garfield did an interview with
entertainment tonight and there were
three clips that went out on twitter the
main thing that people were saying to me
big part of this story is sharing an
experience about him and toby maguire
sneaking into theaters
and haven't heard it yet what i do is i
got these three clips dropped them in a
final cut then exported them so that
we're going to react to it in real time
with you guys talk about it and i hear
there's like additional stuff there too
being asked about a returning perhaps i
think either just a return or for
amazing spider-man 3 i'm not sure where
the question is let's see what's going
on today
[Music]
i snuck into a theater on opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on my mask and just kind of
like in fact i was actually with toby me
and toby snuck into a theater together
no one knew we were there
it was just a really beautiful thing to
share together and to find a brotherhood
with toby as well we and with tom and
and the fact that we have shared a very
unique experience i'm so happy that i
get to talk about that that is crazy can
you imagine being in that theater and
not knowing that you acquired
your garfield is right behind you so
many people were sitting here going was
it mine was i there actually i remember
uh toby mcguire talked one i forgot what
interview it was but he did talk about
it you sneak into the back of the
theaters and watch them have fun um i i
have i i
i remember on the first spider-man a
bunch of us like took a
a bus and rode around and
um
and went to a couple of theaters and and
watched for you know pieces of the film
it makes it more full circle in a
personal life sense i'm so happy that i
get to talk about it now like first and
foremost i am a fan so when amy's gonna
be really kevin feige and john watts
asked to have a word with me and talk to
me about an idea and they and they
pitched it it was like i was the fans in
the audience watching it on screen for
the first time with like the three
spider-man
universes are sharing a frame together
and like your little head just explodes
so like that's the main thing in me that
i'm that i feel about it and then the
fact that i get to be one of those
people wearing the suit next to my
actual spider-man hero toby maguire and
the brilliant
incredibly talented heartfelt funny good
sweet perfect spiderman of tom holland
and i get to be the middle brother and i
get to be like in awe of my older
brother and full longing to protect my
younger brother you know what's so cool
about hearing that or like saying like
he's the middle brother of it all like
it does feel that way in the movie his
franchise is the middle franchise and he
has talked about that before of like
toby maguire was like a big inspiration
to me he was like my hero obviously for
me tobey maguire was my original
like fell in love with that um you know
that the film version of that character
toby who was just this defining figure
in my life i think what he embodies so
well him and tom hall and both i would
say is being true fans of spider-man
like that seems to be really front and
center i don't even get that vibe really
from toby mcguire
like to kill up the character but i
don't feel like he's like oh spider-man
you know whereas like andrew garfield
and and tom holland being i think what
they do so well is sharing their
personal feelings and i think why we
connect so much with them is because
their level of appreciation and fandom
for spider-man does connect with all of
us he is us and two i mean even thinking
about the variety article just that
thing he said about it being this
service to the many you know through a
character like that you know i can
absolutely see that and just the
gratitude he seems to show and the
enthusiasm overall and it does like
authentically even though they're
disconnected franchises feel like they
are three brothers related you know all
in the same walk of life or at least on
the same path of life it's one of the
few moments where cinema and life can
kind of converge to give you something
that's both satisfying just as a story
but also satisfying as like just a life
experience
i mean you know never say never i mean
it's a character that's always gonna be
so meaningful to me and so beautiful to
me and again it comes back to service i
think if there's a way
for me to continue to add to the legacy
of that character in a way that feels of
service to an audience of service to the
themes that stan lee you know injected
that character with i'm open of course
i'm very very open but but it would have
to be very very special it would have to
be very very meaningful and fun and
joyful
i think i think that could happen
i think we could find a meaningful
joyful story to tell venom symbiote
let's get it going
crossover again multiverse let's get
toby back and tom back and we'll get
miles morales in there miguel o'haran
well i i absolutely think that there is
a story to be told with andrew garfield
spider-man that can definitely be served
upon those themes i think there's a
reason why a lot of us would want the
amazing spider-man 3. his version does
bring something so different and his
journey in particular even the one
that's teased in no way home brings
something so so much more unique kind of
what we've been getting prior and i
think a lot of us would really want to
see that i think too what's cool about
how he's presenting this is he's not
just willing to say yes to anything yeah
so what's great about this is he doesn't
seem like he's
like ambivalent towards it he's
completely receptive and would love to
he just would want it to make sure it's
the right story and i feel like even
after the experiences of how amazing
spider-man 2 was received i think he
would want to be that way because even
he seems like he understood the depth of
amazing spider-man 2 like he talked
about in that variety interview of
saying that movie's about fate and as
much as i grew to appreciate that movie
on my re-watch i never actually looked
at it like that like oh yeah this really
is about fate yeah yeah absolutely for
sure i mean i think that is also part of
the equation is knowing how you know
that second movie was received and some
of the flaws that do stand with it i
think you know as much as there is the
enthusiasm and the momentum writing off
of everybody wanting him to come back
and him obviously being you know joyous
at the prospect yeah i think it would
want to be the kind of thing where it's
well thought out and it is something
that will be truly special and impactful
like we could get him back for any
number of things and it has to be the
right thing and i appreciate that that's
the wavelength he's on and especially
hearing about how marvel was like what
do you want to do who he had sony with
like what do you want to explore i think
that's a good position to be coming from
you know all right guys well did you
catch andrew garfield and toby mcguire
in the back of the theater with you
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do a pic
daniel gallacher manager garfield's been
talking about service and if there's
somebody at our patreon who embodies the
spirit of service
that would be you and not for any of the
obvious reasons dan it's because of the
love and support you show us
every month for the past several odd
years my friend i can't believe that
you're still here and that you're still
enjoying i i assume hopefully enjoying
these shout outs and the content that we
bring to you that's a service we like to
provide back to you because of all the
love and joy that you show us
so hey it's the new year i just wanted
to wish you well at the start of 2022. i
know new years don't really mean a ton
of actual stuff but hey there's joyous
potential and opportunity in the air and
i hope that you're able to take
advantage of that this coming year much
love buddy and we'll talk soon
[Music]
you